um
he was always uh felt like devastated
that john and he was looking forward
for junior to come out as were we but
the problem is junior got hit with the
curtis leewa
uh charges and they kept him in jail so
greg actually made a phone call with an
fbi phone that he contacted
the family of john gotti jr saying hey
you know when is he getting out
and and all of that and they said they
had some problems with him
so they there was always this thing with
greg
and others that it was always trying to
get to the top and do whatever
it was necessary in fact when i was out
there with him uh
and we charged arnold scutieri the
acting boss and magaly
he had um arnos gutierrez
and alfonsisca called fonzie who was
also
a captain in the gambinos they shook
down this
very well to do a guy and they took his
american express
black not platinum but blackguard
and there they went on a spending spree
with their wives
to vegas and then after like 20 000
being spent they cut the card off
and we have it on tape because i was
wearing the recorder
when they're calling in they're saying
you tell this guy to reactivate his car
that's an embarrassment to me
that this card was cut off my and these
guys were like kids in the candy stores
their wives were doing manny patties
hair dude
they were shopping in the malls of the
uh of the casinos
it's it was just insane of the abuse
that they did
but again there goes greg kissing up
to the bosses so he would be okay with
them
as opposed to a guy who sits quiet and
then when it comes to take somebody out
they say well what good is this guy he
doesn't put
any money in my pocket i mean i remember
i
sold i i we came up with a scheme of uh
giving plasma tvs and this actually
happened which i think you'll find it
amazing so
instead of buying it uh uh
a plasma tv i told them i fell off the
back of the truck and my guys got it
so we give it to arnold schware now
arnos gutierrez home
watching the sopranos now do you
remember the scene where robert leogia
with feech lamanna comes out of prison
and things have changed and he's a
little threatening to tony soprano
because he was old school he didn't like
the way things were worked yeah so they
set him up
by putting and storing these plasma tvs
in the garage
and then drop a dime to the probation
officer
and boom he gets arrested uh again feet
lamanna
well what happened is greg the palmer
calls me in the morning he says i gotta
see you
i says you're not gonna believe what
happened yesterday i know it's true but
i gotta ask you anyway
is that television stolen i go what do
you think greg
well i think i went to the store of
course the story goes i knew it
last night i got a call from the boss
he's watching that damn soprano show
and they talking about these plasma tvs
because he too was on parole
and he says get this thing out of my
house and get it out of there now
they yank the tv out of the wall just
for fear
so you talk about life imitating art
that was it
that was a perfect example so you know
so this is again greg
immediately volunteers when i told him i
had a couple that fell off the back of
the truck
let's give it to the boss you know
that's the way he
always buttered up everybody and he was
a master at
i mean he would see you patrick and he'd
be
thinking how do i get in your pocket how
do i get in your business
you know and then he'll say okay he's
looking for ways to exploit you
that's what he does with everybody
because that's the nature of the beast
with these guys
that's natural dude that's not just it's
not let me ask you a question a gift
how do they get tr is there a training
for that or no you just see somebody do
it and you learn it and you pick it up
meaning
is is more caught or taught you know
it's something i think growing up in
these neighborhoods
these guys are not boy scouts as you
know they're out there committing crimes
as kids
then they wind up going to jail or jail
is like going to oxford
to these guys they're sitting around
prison they're talking about
scams here scams that they got in the
future
there's always a way to making money but
it's in their dna
i've gone out with greg the palmer to
the big man shop
that they had in new york city called uh
uh
anyway it skips me this beautiful store
they had on fifth avenue
right we walk in i'm looking at clothes
right here's greg the palmer sticking
ties
socks down his pants i go what are you
doing so he goes what do you mean what
i'm doing i said we're gonna take a
pinch over here you're robbing
i'll buy them for you give them to me he
goes nah forget that he goes jackie this
is what we do
you know this is who i am so it's
their dna they are thieves they are
criminals and they could be putting on
their fedoras
they could be pious men with fedoras and
45s
but they're nothing but criminals that's
all they are interesting and they're
looking to get in people's pocket
and without any remorse you think that
can ever change with them you think that
part can ever change
no and i think i think i'm probably the
only guy who feels that the mafia is
going to come back
and i'll tell you why in the fbi the
investigative priorities
of organized crime is it's so low i mean
right now we have terrorism
uh cyber uh foreign counter intelligence
it's not even in the top ten where when
i was working and we were in the top ten
now what happened is they consolidated
five squads
into three squads and they got rid of a
lot of guys on the task force
so what do you think is going on if
there's nobody there
to pursue these guys yeah they're doing
what they're supposed to we are they're
a criminal secret society
they've crawled back under the rocks and
they're making their moves in a way
knowing
that they're not being looked at simply
because we don't have the manpower to do
it
that's interesting for you to say that
they could be coming back so
uh because you know merlino was in
something recently with the election
four weeks ago that his name came up uh
that he may have been involved in the
scandal of elections and you know mob
has been involved with elections for god
knows how many years since
dewey days you know way way back with
elections but
you know so so you're saying it's in
their dna you don't think it can change
so you don't think
one of these things about hey you know
i'm a changed man right now i don't have
the same tendency as of trying to get
money out of your pocket and i'm living
a straight life
you think it's something that will never
ever go away once they're in it for 20
30 40 years
listen first of all i commend you for
the hosts the guests that you've had
on your shows i mean you've had some
serious heavyweight guys
i mean sammy the bull i mean come on he
is
he's a bad guy period 19 murders
you know i i mean he's uh he's a tough
guy on the street
you know uh you've had phil leonetti
another one it's i mean these are
serious guys
now have they changed or are they
capable of changing
i don't know it's if you you know what's
the old saying you can't change the spot
of a leopard
are you gonna change this i mean sammy
had his shot to be changed and then he
went into
ecstasy and he got collet so i don't
know i
i hope that they see their light to see
whether it's possible
but would you want to be their next door
neighbor
you